the heels of that report nevada  averaging 22 thousand vaccines given  every day as of tonight so far a little  more than 20 percent of the state's  population is now  fully vaccinated statewide more than 1.5  million doses have been given  locally that number has now surpassed  1.1 million doses brian  well the daily average of new cases  continues to level off in our state of  nevada sitting at 236 tonight  that is a major drop from the average of  2 200 cases a day in january  nevada's two-week average in deadly  cases of the virus still at three  our state's test positivity rate has  risen slightly  in the last few days to just above five  percent